So, you tap the video icon and all of a sudden, you'll go into video mode.
Slide over, you've got a separate capture button.
All you have to do is hold down the button to start recording the video.
So let's do that.
So, let's say we're at Blue Bottle Coffee.
They're using a Japanese siphon machine that makes some really beautiful coffee.
We're recording our first clip here of the barista at Blue Bottle.
Now, we wanna add some color of pulling a shot of the espresso.
This is making me thirsty.
So, we see the next shot of pulling some espresso,...
...and then finally, let's see the barista applying a beautiful latte.
So, here we are pouring the beautiful latte and I'm recording it by holding down that button.
All we gotta do is touch the little delete button on the bottom left.
It highlights the last clip and deletes it.
So, let's re-record that last one to get a better collage.
My friends are gonna be way more excited about watching this video,...
...if they get to see the really cool latte.
So, when I click next, you'll see the preview.
This is what people are gonna see in the feed.
I can fill out my caption that I want my friends to see.
Hashtags work just the same way.